protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News
oh thank you very much you're watching
flight coming up on the show this week
rise of the soft machines is this the
future of robotics kid stuff we meet the
next generation of engineers getting
their experience in early plus it's
business time we send the sims to work
in our games with you hello and welcome
to swipe it's the Easter holidays and
we're at a Children's robotics camp now
I know what you're thinking we've been a
little bit obsessed with robotics
recently here on swype but it's not
without good reason you've all heard
stories about how one day robots might
rule the world and there's a whole area
of robotics we haven't even told you
about soft robotics never heard of it
here's to it
for the uninitiated this is a good
introduction to soft robotics baymax
from Disney's oscar-winning film big
hero 6 has machinery on the inside but
is inflatable on the outside professor
Chris åkesson and his team at Carnegie
Mellon University in Pittsburgh helped
the filmmakers ensure their movie was
based on real technology what we're
worried about is getting close to people
and touching them if you want to comb
someone's here or brush their teeth you
really want a robot that's not going to
hurt them even if the computer crashes
so for me soft robotics is building
computers that are inherently safe even
if they have a computer crash you might
think baymax looks far-fetched but this
kind of tech is being developed in real
life right now like traditional machines
soft robots are durable and relatively
expendable but this technology takes
inspiration from nature using materials
which have strengths but won't
necessarily damage what they come into
contact with experts say there are many
potential uses one of the things that
you might want to do is with soft
robotics is to use them in medical
applications so for things where you
were moving inside the body when you
have forceps for example and you're
moving tissues apart or somewhere where
you're using a machine in an unstable
environment to say instead of kind of
rubble type environments say after an
earthquake or a disaster zone and by
having a machine this soft that can
gently move in the environment and
interact with the environment safely
then you can remove some of the control
elements that you'll need for
conventional hard robotic systems they
could also be used domestically helping
people with restricted movement to wash
eat or fetch things for example but
perhaps most importantly they could
change how we feel about interacting
closely with machines it's about showing
that robots aren't necessarily these
scary hard machines and it's moving
robots into something where people will
be interested interacting with and
they'll feel safe interacting with
later this month industry experts will
gather at the world's first soft
robotics week in Tuscany Italy they'll
be discussing how they can make sure
these prototypes evolve into the future
of robotics Stuart Duggan Sky News well
all engineers have to start somewhere
and here they're learning the basics of
robotics using Lego you can so hello so
nice to meet you can I shake this hand
Michelle you didn't make it to do that
it's very clever looking how long did
that take them it took me two and a half
hours does it mean yeah what is it you
like about building things I like that
you can just let let your imagination
news film whatever you want whatever one
second this thing over here is one of
your teachers Simon now when you were
young did you start getting into into
engineering like this I started very
young all the way through wooden blocks
then into normal Lego and then moving on
stuff like necks and Meccano and all the
way into a degree in engineering one
thing that strikes me though there
aren't many girls here are there it's a
bit of a boys thing would you agree yes
on my degree in engineering I found that
there are only a few girls in class of a
few hundred but there are only female
engineers out there they just don't get
as much press indeed now so what do you
want to go on to do with this project
now you want to make a whole robot out
of it you're watching swipe still to
come on the show acceptable in the
eighties some platform-based retro fun
and are gay
but first here's a roundup of some of
this week's other tech news how'd it go
on Google Maps pac-man I couldn't get
Stuart off it users have been able to
transform maps of real streets into
playable zones styled on the popular
1980s arcade game when the update
launched a few days ago Google said it
would only be around for a little while
it was still there when we filmed this
so happy chomping while you can
Nass has been continuing its mission to
find new ways to land on Mars by spin
testing one of its spacecrafts in the
lab this week ahead of a test flight in
June the low density supersonic
decelerator aka ldsd is a bit of a cross
between a balloon and a flying saucer
it's intended to better handle the
tricky atmosphere on the Red Planet a
new health tracking project in the u.s.
is aiming to test the DNA of thousands
of people by using Facebook the team
behind genes for good is hoping
volunteers will use a special Facebook
app to answer questions and send a
sample of their spit to a laboratory at
the University of Michigan the project
is to help scientists learn more about
genes and disease jay-z launched his new
music streaming service this week
Madonna Beyonce and Alicia Keys are
among the a-listers who co-owned the
venture called tidal it's meant to give
artists more control over music
streaming after many complained they get
little in return for the rights to
stream their work on sites like Spotify
stick to Google Mouse pac-man speaking
of video games here's guy Cocker with
some of the latest releases ride is a
new game from the Italian developers
milestone and they have a lot of form in
making motorbike games they made the
MotoGP series for a few years back and
this is their attempt to try and make a
motorbike version of grants reeseman so
if you play grounds for reason where
you'll know that it's a very serious
racing sim it's all about buying in that
case cars and upgrading them and take
around some the most beautiful tracks in
the world and that's very much the same
for ride but on two wheels so you start
your racing career you buy the bikes you
have to tweak them and the handling is
very very realistic now there's
different levels of realism that you can
adjust but even on the most sort of
basic novice difficulty level I was
struggling to get into the game and
actually sort of ride particularly while
I was falling off all the time so if you
like that sort of simulation aspect of
most by racing then this is the game for
you now get to work brings some of the
most popular elements of gameplay from
previous versions of the Sims which are
jobs back into into the sims it's an
expansion pack so you have to buy it but
it brings that that game played a lot of
fans night back to the series so you
essentially get a Sim you choose a job
and be a doctor you can be in for a
private investigator or a scientist and
depending on what career path you take
if you're the detective for example you
start off doing simple jobs and
supporting the other detectives with
paperwork and then you get to start to
investigate your own cases and
interrogate the perps and do all that
sort of stuff and if you're a scientist
you get to start doing experiments and
doing even right up to the point where
you're investigating other alien planets
so they have quite a lot of fun with
this idea of careers it's got that sort
of Sims element of of human today so
while it's good it's not an essential
expansionpak it really just brings the
sims 4 to were probably fans expecting
it to be in the bottom ice axiom verge
like so many other games from indie
developers as a take on the classic
Metroid style gameplay now Metroid was a
massive hit for Nintendo back in the 80s
and there have been many other
variations on Metroid and in the past
but this looks very much like an 80s
style game right down to the simple
8-bit sort of blocky graphics and the
chiptune soundtrack but it's very much
in a march to that Metroid style
gameplay so you start off you're a
scientist you get sucked into this alien
world you start off with a simple weapon
and
you pick up the drill and then you would
pick up on a another weapon that allows
you to corrupt and D corrupt the game
world the idea is that you explore this
alien world and then use these weapons
to investigate the areas that you'd
already been to and then open up new
areas and that's very much a sort of
from a game design perspective what
Metroid did so well in this game very
much follows that Metroid Metroid style
gameplay I have any complaints about it
and this might be from a PlayStation 4
owner who's you know spent 300 pound 350
pounds on a console that can produce
lifelike graphics is why you would maybe
buy again that looks like it could have
been made about 20 years ago but if
you're a massive fan of Metroid style
games and 80s style classic platforming
and shooting then actually this is
probably one of the best examples
well that's it for this week don't
forget you can stay up to date with all
the latest tech stories and sky news for
iPad our smartphone app sky news calm
and our YouTube playlist see you again
next week
protect your bubble comm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News